what's going on guys this is Rob and
welcome back to another top 10 list
let's get into it FYI this video is
going to get pretty dark and the number
one choice that we have here for the
darkest most disturbing controversial
moments in Marvel Comics is pretty
Twisted starting off the list at number
10 is a story where the Punisher became
a black man so this is a story called
The Punisher final days and basically
it's a story where by Frank Castle had
been in a prison and in order to escape
he had impersonated the body of somebody
else and so when he got out he went to a
plastic surgeon and instructed that guy
to basically make him look
unrecognizable so the plastic surgeon
turned him into a black guy now we ended
up teaming up with Luke Cage and I'm
pretty sure he gave himself the name
Frank Rook so nobody would really know
who he was obviously the writer of the
story at the time was immediately kicked
off the title and he was replaced with
somebody else who basically fixed
everything up and kind of got it back to
you as good as it could get but this is
one of those stories that Marvel Comics
doesn't want anybody to know having said
that this is about as loud lighthearted
as we get uh it gets Bleak over the
course of this it gets very very dark
but coming in at number nine is Captain
America eating human flesh now this
turns our attention to Marvel ruins and
you're definitely going to see Marvel
ruins again on this list because how
could you not so here's the thing in
this story we don't directly see it
happen instead we basically learned
about this by way of Nick Fury now one
of the things we find out here before
Nick Fury takes out Jean Gray and
himself is that he actually eats human
flesh and he was introduced to it by
Captain America now we talked about
Marvel ruins before in the last video
that we did and we're gonna talk about
it again over the course of these lists
if we're focusing on really really dark
content from all the comics because
Marvel ruins is as dark as it gets it is
the most just dark story unnecessarily
dark that Marvel Comics has ever made
but basically it's a story where the
worst possible scenario that can happen
does happen and in fact we could
literally make a video that's the
darkest moments from Marvel ruins which
would just be a bleak video in and of
itself but the thing about this is that
it's a terrible situation and it's
pretty much a very dark and Bleak
depiction of the superheroes as we know
them from Marvel Comics we do have the
video here at Commons explain we have
covered it feel free to check it out
you'll find a link to it down in the
description but moving on to number
eight and if this doesn't give you any
indication of how dark this list is
going to get then nothing else will
ultimates three and the reason why that
matters is because we end up learning in
the ultimate universe that Quicksilver
and Scarlet witch who are brother and
sister are basically banging it's pretty
messed up and in fact Wolverine watches
it happen because Wolverine is a really
weird and twisted guy in the Ultimate
Universe those of you guys who don't
know what that is the Ultimate Universe
was a line of comics introduced by
Marvel in the year 2000 and started with
Ultimate Spider-Man that was an answer
to the question what would superheroes
look like if they were just being
introduced so it's like a modern take on
superheroes the Marvel Cinematic
Universe gets most of its material from
a combination of the Ultimate Universe
comics and the Earth 98 Comics so it's a
pretty cruel line of stories to tell but
that one's pretty messed up and it's
pretty weird but it's not nearly as dark
as the stuff we're gonna get into
because now we get into The Bleak stuff
it's been lighthearted up to this point
it's been like I mean it's a little bit
controversial you know a little suspect
right now it gets into the dark stuff so
coming in at number seven more Lon rips
out Spider-Man's eye and eats it so for
those of you guys who never read a story
called Marvel the other and I don't know
why I'm smiling about this I got a
morbid sense of humor the only thing I
should never read a story called The
Other it basically dealt with the idea
that Peter Parker was what was called a
spider totem basically meaning that he
represents spiders on like the totem of
animals so like black panther for
example represents the Panther on the
animal totem different things like that
more Lun is what's called an inheritor
he's a guy that basically travels around
and targets spiders more than anybody
else but basically wants to kill any
anybody who represents the spider totem
so any member of this fight or family
Spider-Man Spider Girl Spider Woman so
on and so forth and then consume their
energies and in fact he was such a
threat that the inheritors became a
multiversal team that was tracking down
and killing every version of Spider-Man
they could find across the Multiverse
that's actually the entire basis for the
original spider-verse event in Marvel
Comics by Dan slot it was a phenomenal
story and this one when Moreland is
facing off against Spider-Man he beats
him within an inch of his life and then
he rips his eyeball out and then he eats
his eyeball now Peter regrows his
eyeball in the next issue but it was a
pretty brutal moment when that happened
you never really saw things that dark
taking place in Spider-Man comics but
this leads us into number six which is a
story called The Last Avengers story
this is a story that initially focused
on Ultron who was always being defeated
by the superheroes taking the memes by
which the superheroes could be defeated
and then putting it in a time capsule
Kane the Conqueror eventually discovers
it travels back to the modern era and
then detonates a nuclear bomb Over The
Avengers Mansion which kills most all
the Avengers who were there those
Avengers who don't die in this story
basically end up just becoming really
old and they effectively age out but
Hank Pam who's basically really fat and
old ends up forming a new Avengers team
though one of the things you learn which
this puts it in the number six spot one
of the things you learn is that in a
flashback there came a point where the
Incredible Hulk who is basically evil
faced off against Tigra and Wonder Man
and what had happened is that in front
of Wonder Man Tigra had attacked the
Incredible Hulk believing she could
basically slash his eyes out because
she's basically a tiger in terms of how
her physical appearance is as well as
like her powers to a degree The
Incredible Hulk grabs her pulls her in
front of him and then rips her to pieces
in front of Wonder Man like literally
blood flying everywhere it's chaotic
it's disgusting but it's one of the most
brutal moments that you're ever going to
see in Marvel Comics especially when it
comes to the Incredible Hulk but coming
in at number five is a story called The
Amazing Spider-Man shed and this focuses
and I know a lot of you guys who are
huge fans of Spider-Man knew this was
coming this focuses on the lizard Dr
Kirk Connor she's basically in more of
an animalistic State than anything else
but it shows the darkest version of his
character that the lizard historically
speaking in Marvel Comics has been
depicted as a pretty violent guy he's
done some pretty violent things in this
instance the lizard goes insane and eats
his son alive and you watch it happen in
the comic it's pretty brutal and it's
pretty disgusting and one of the
absolute most disturbing moments in the
entirety of Marvel Comics which is
really weird again considering the fact
that it's a Spider-Man comic where this
happens but coming in at number four and
we're rapidly approaching the top three
like I said number one is Twisted coming
in at number 4. we have one of my
absolute favorite moments in Marvel
Comics which is Punisher killing tiberio
and the slaver story arc now as you guys
know from these list videos that we make
once we get to the top four that's when
we really start getting into the
nitty-gritty of this right so the whole
idea behind the slaver story arc is it's
literally Frank Castle dealing with
people that traffic other people the one
that's kind of behind all this is a guy
named tiberio and the way that it's
explained this guy's Old Testament Man
Fire Brimstone he's like just way back
in the day how they used to do things
he's one of the only characters that you
see in Garth Innes Punisher MAX they can
actually go toe-to-toe with Frank Castle
in terms of just violence and brutality
but eventually Frank Castle gets a hold
of this guy and Frank Castle realizes
this guy is basically coming from
Eastern Europe so what Frank Castle does
is he ties this guy to a chair and he
sets up a camera and literally just
records the whole thing just hits the
record button he doesn't really say a
whole lot it's what he does did he
realize is when it comes to those guys
in that part of the world actions speak
louder than words that if Frank Castle
said stuff like you guys can't come back
here I'm gonna kill you if you do they
wouldn't take him seriously he uses
Tiberia as an example he douses this guy
in gasoline and sets him on fire in
front of the camera and then just looks
at the camera and says don't come back
here it was insanely brutal and amazing
But continuing our Trend with this list
and talking about Frank Castle let's get
into the number three spot now this was
not Punisher MAX but was actually Marvel
Knights The Punisher which was also
written by Garth Innis with a story
called vertical Challenge and aim low
with issue 16 and 17. this is a story
where basically Frank Castle kind of
kills Wolverine as close as you can the
way this plays out he blows off
Wolverine's face with a shotgun he hits
him in the castle with a baseball bat
and smashes him and then he blows them
off using an Uzi and then while
Wolverine is just suffering and
agonizing in pain Frank Castle runs him
over with a steamroller it's pretty
intense and the most Punisher MAX thing
ever but now we get into the number two
spot we're rapidly approaching number
one which is dark we get into the number
two spot this one's gonna be a little
bit controversial but I feel like this
is certainly one of the darkest
disturbing controversial moments
whatever in Marvel Comics basically
anything from Maximum Carnage now for
those of you guys who aren't familiar
with this story this was not the first
time that Carnage appeared in Marvel
Comics but it is the most violent what
made this so incredibly violent is that
Carnage the way he was depicted in this
story was an answer to the question what
if the Joker got the Venom Symbian how
crazy would he be what Carnage does over
the course of this story until he's
eventually caught up to by Spider-Man
and Venom is Carnage will basically kill
people and then use their blood and
right Maximum Carnage on walls or
Carnage Rules or different things like
that sometimes he would even use his own
blood but it was just the level of hyper
violence in this story that gives us a
reason it at least gives me a reason to
put this at number two people are being
disemboweled people are being eaten
people are just being killed in some of
the most gruesome ways even in the early
1990s when the story was done it wasn't
a ridiculously violent story and that's
why I put it here at number two but
number one nothing on this list that
we've done so far is as disturbing or
screwed up as the number one spot this
again comes from Marvel ruins and it's
Emma Frost cult so what we learn here
and it's not a great big huge hyper
focal part of the story that's one of
the things you'll learn about Marvel
ruins is it's basically things that
you're told at either the end of the
story or it's just something mentioned
in passing but what we end up finding
out here is that in the main Marvel
Universe Emma Frost has been a member of
the hellfire club that Emma Frost has
led her own team called Generation X
which was like her version of the X-Men
more or less she also led a team called
the hellions who were basically
destroyed which is what led her to
basically join the X-Men and lead
generation X in the first place but in
the ruins Universe she's the leader of a
cult and what they do is because the IMO
Frost is so ridiculously wealthy she
goes to parents who are struggling
financially and offers to buy their kits
and if the parents are okay with it
she'll purchase them and then give them
like a huge amount of money then they
take the kids and they just perform
these experiments on them that are
usually pretty gruesome to see if they
can give them powers or to see if they
have powers or something like that it's
dark and it's Bleak and it's Twisted Q
demonetization from YouTube but it's a
really really really
dark and twisted thing to see people
like human beings just being treated
that way right being lobotomized or like
their heads being cut open and all that
kind of stuff and just the look of
misery and despair on their faces it's
more than enough to put this at the
number one spot now there are some some
things some moments out there from like
Marvel ruins and even like Earth X and
stuff like that they're legitimate
contenders for the number one spot but
honestly I think this is probably the
single darkest and most disturbing
moment in the entirety of Marvel Comics
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this to an end thank you all
for watching and I'll catch you all
later
peace